the Joe Rogan experience Eddie remember
when I had a bucket handle tear you had
a drive into the [ __ ] doctors MRI
show my NSX do that man so he could
drive he drove his NSX a little sports
car yep I could write the chip
brothers 98 sons but I ship in a while
you know what I mean cuz when you're
poor a stick shift means you're poor and
I can in in the Mexican hood
once you get your automatic from the
bounds of those ideas rich white people
like stitcher listen why you got to get
racing so once I got into automatics and
like [ __ ] you know I got Pat beyond the
stick ship now he's got like a
high-performance diction and I say I
gotta drive to the doctor D I've never
seen this [ __ ] shotgun in the club
drive a stick-shift
cars restriction that was the easiest
car to shift ever understand as far as
shifting cars go no you have to
understand like I have to speak out as a
car 98 somewhere around there maybe a
2000 at the latest 2000 though those
years NSX we're a marvel one of the best
cars of all time and you were so
connected when you put it when you put
that [ __ ] in reverse or any gear
I wish you still have it the feeling I
should probably get another one the feel
of the clutch was magical
it wasn't the grinding it was the anger
dude
kissed me when he was so pissed off
because it's the he was already and I'm
[ __ ] this car we're going my dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing I was having
a hard time and it was visiting my buddy
and you know what another great story
about a sax it was when I finally after
six months of getting in his ear about
smoking weed I was like trying to
convince him to smoke weed I'm like not
so funny he's so funny without weed I go
if I could get him to smoke me cuz
everything everybody thought I was crazy
for smoking weed
so back in back in the day and then I
finally convinced them we were in his
NSX he pulls over and he goes okay
[ __ ] pull it out I'm like not right
now pull it out I go dude no no I
convinced them I finally convinced them
to smoke weed but it was why we were
driving six months people's articles
pull it out I told them I like I didn't
drive for six months when I started
smoking weed I wouldn't drive I was too
scared and goes dude let's just do it
I'm like yeah I'm like listen to me and
I go [ __ ] we gotta go to [ __ ]
baskin-robbins he's got to feel that
[ __ ] cuz this is it I finally convinced
them to do it that's good is there an
ice cream place there's a baskin-robbins
down on Topanga I go lift foot we made
up you know that first time he never
stopped after that that was that was it
that was it and then check this out
every day but there was some ups and
downs but down I remember that night
that night we went to Baskin Robbins he
had a [ __ ] hot fudge sundae and we
went to the comedy store and he got on
stage the first night he smoked weed and
this joke I'll never Freddy goes dude I
got high for the first time today
and damn I didn't realize hot fudge
sundaes were so [ __ ] good the crowd
go nuts yeah he did it early not how I
said
[Applause]